bravo tu es là je me demandais où tu
étais ça va insomnie tu as envie d'en
parler j'en ai déjà longuement parlé à
ce pot de glace je te fais un petit p o
au chus main droite
oh c'est pas drôle ça cool que quelqu'un
tu rentres d'aujourd'hui
christian pourquoi y'a personne
ils sont sortis tu es plus fâché contre
moi
dans le toit
[Musique]
je t'emmène dans la salle de jeux
tu voudras des enfants quand même un
jour turban oui un jour t'as pas l'air
si sûr que ça je suis sûr d'un truc par
contre est ce steak et délicieusement
christian tu ne veux pas d'enfant alors
bien sûr que si plus tard là c'est trop
tôt je suis pas prêt à partager avec
personne
fait la promesse d mais finalement et de
te protéger
à lever les yeux au ciel je rêve pas tu
envisages des représailles je passe te
prendra cinq heures sauf si je n'ai pas
terminé d'ici là
alors pourquoi tu désolé madame mais
c'est pour te protéger
or quelle nouvelle bana nous sommes
suivis
[Musique]
bonjour enfants bonjour madame grès
regarder par la fenêtre
je vous emmène en week end j'ai du mal à
croire que c'est ma vie que j'ai la
chance de vivre avec toi
je me
euroda n'agrège écoute
je passe te prendra cinq heures sauf si
je n'ai pas terminé d'ici là week
je peux conduire non
elle est magnifique je vais acheter pour
nous jeunes adorent crestian tu
elle est idéalement situé je vais vous
construire une maison de rêve
arrêtez de parler à mon mari comme si je
n'étais pas là anna vous pouvez
m'appeler madame grès
je devrai désobéir plus souvent
nous sommes suivis
[Musique]
alors qu'une nouvelle anna jack vous
voulez quoi
[Musique]
tu as envie de jouer oui monsieur
je tiens
j'ai juré de te protéger je le ferais tu
ne peux pas m'enfermer dans une cage
j'ai fait la promesse de thé mais
finalement en renonçant à toute autre tu
as couché avec
et de te réconforter dans la détresse
aussi longtemps que nous vivons pourquoi
est ce que tu me défi
parce que je te tiens ce beau